yeah growing up i i i left home when i
was 10. so like
i had to kind of i guess that is a
cancer trait but put on your
you know your wall your protection your
armor and just keep going
and that was my motto is just just keep
going just keep going just keep going
and yeah just i never really showed
emotion
as a kid and then about three years ago
i just like
broke open and now i can't stop crying
so
and i'm happy about it really running a
lot of parallel paths in our lives
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense on the show today
is the beautiful
julianne huff she's a dancer actress
singer
songwriter and the creator of a new and
amazing
mind-body connective practice called
kinergy which i've done and i find it to
be actually
really amazing but today we talked a lot
about
the journey depth and sometimes
difficulty and pain
i would call her a fellow seeker you
know there's always a there's a burning
desire to go deeper to know more
and to become a true truer sense of
herself
it was just a beautiful conversation
that flowed effortlessly
and i'm gonna say she's my friend now
how i think we need to go wake surfing
yeah have you been like surfing a lot
so i grew up on the lake in um idaho and
then
is that why you have your mountain home
out there yeah yeah
my dad grew up there and then um
[Music]
yeah and then i bought a place there six
years ago and it's just been
like home i've heard that's beautiful
out there is yeah
i mean i have crystalline energy too
it's just it's
just it's bright and yeah
crystals i know right where's like
arizona is a little more like dense or
utah whatever just feels a little bit
more like
true whereas this just was like like you
feel really high
yeah it is heavy rock it's like rocks
yeah which is great i love that too
but yeah it feels more like bright
is the water cold freezing especially
just now i did it in a
wetsuit like three weeks ago and it was
50
something degrees yeah it's cold do you
have an aversion to cold
i don't love the cold but i also just
love the adrenaline so i'm
down to i'm down to do whatever i love
risks yeah well we have that in common
then um
i what what is it what's your
relationship with risk like why what
does it do
i know if if i'm scared to do something
i usually
like it means that i have to do it
that's how i feel yeah
yeah and i used to be so much more of a
daredevil as a kid
and then i've like really chilled out
over the last few years and i'm like i
think i think i need to like find that
again
because it translates i think into work
too and
relationships and everything and i'm
like okay so i just got to go do some
[ __ ] that scares me
and then i'll be cool i can like have
the confidence for work stuff that i
want to
have a little bit more confidence in so
yeah hmm
yeah that's i i find that put me in a
car opposite
yeah obviously we should go to the
racetrack go wake surfing there's
probably a list of things
um jump out of plane um uh it was the
opposite for me i realized that
um what motivated me in racing was uh
like i mean a lot of
it's not just one single thing but i
really love pushing that boundary
yeah and so really what i loved about it
was um
getting uncomfortable and sort of
getting up against that all the time so
just what you're saying
and so while i was racing i didn't like
to do anything crazy otherwise
i actually would have been called uh
like
not brave yeah and since i've stopped
racing
now i'm like my freedom yes yeah yes yes
yeah what else do you do that's not
brave well hang on i mean like because
there's like brave as in like physical
yeah but then to me you also partake in
the brave emotional
mm-hmm yeah i don't know i mean for me i
i'm a cancer so like i've always been
known to be emotional but i actually
never showed that
um i am the baby of five and so growing
up i was sort of like the responsible
one even though
i was the baby i was kind of like taking
care of everybody making sure everybody
was good
and then yeah growing up i i left home
when i was 10. so like
i had to kind of i guess that is a
cancer trait but put on your
you know your wall your protection your
armor and just keep going
and that was my motto is just just keep
going just keep going just keep going
and yeah just i never really showed
emotion as a kid
and then about three years ago i just
like broke open
and now i can't stop crying so
and i'm happy about it really running a
lot of parallel paths in our lives
what did you leave home for at 10. i
moved to london
yeah i moved to london and lived with my
dance coaches there i was only supposed
to stay for three months
and then it ended up being five years oh
my god
yeah that's yeah that's incredible
because people
i mean i lived in england for three
years too when i was 16 though
and people would still say like that's
crazy so what'd you do about school did
you
i went to performing arts school so i
got a scholarship to go to school
i danced with my coach's son um
yeah it was weird because again as a kid
i was
so much more mature than i am now i
think i like
had my [ __ ] together you know and even
as a kid i look back and everybody was
cool with me going to london
i look at my nieces and nephews now yeah
who are
13 and i'm like i wouldn't put you on
you know a bus
by yourself right like i want to see
where you're riding your bicycle
exactly and it's like how did that even
happen
but you know it's it's part of the
course i guess but
um yeah it was it was definitely an
intense living situation too because
i was 10 i moved there i went to you
know school
all day long and then we would practice
and you know until 11 o'clock at night
and then we would compete on the
weekends
and travel all over europe and so and
like i would have all the fake tan
because ballroom and latin dancing
you know fake tan the long red nails
like
the whole thing and and it was quite
confusing because
i was 10 but i was kind of overtly
like mature and sexualized as a kid and
like
dancing and it's you know but it was
very much in my nature to be that
naturally but it was embraced and
celebrated
and so the more i did it the more i was
rewarded by it
but then it was confusing because then
being a kid where i just wanted to like
play barbies and hang out
yeah that's what i was doing you know
like i didn't do that
and so i i really felt like not that i
lost my childhood it was just a
different kind of childhood
and so now i'm like i'm playing with
barbies now
do you feel like you're reflaming it
because i do i think that there's
something to
incorporating every phase of traditional
sort of
growing up that ends up happening and
it's not always in order
no i i went back to my 10 year old self
uh
when i was 25
and i kind of like lived in that 10 year
old phase
and like kind of grew up basically
from like 25 to like 28
and then 28 something shifted
29 it was like
i i broke like my like emotions started
coming out and i was like
this is this is me as a woman this isn't
the little this isn't little julianne
running the show anymore this is me as a
woman and i'm completely different and
i'm
totally petrified that nobody's gonna
like this version
because the the the hard ass that
started when i was like 18 because i was
like this
really mature got my [ __ ] together kind
of girl went into that like
little girl from like 18 to 25 then 25
to like 29
and then it was like just a whole new
layer of
of i think who i am now and dropping
into more of the woman
in me and nobody really experienced
that part i hadn't even this was totally
new so
yeah the the safety and the comfort zone
kind of just went away
so you said that you were more mature
you thought when you went to england
when you were
10 what does that mean well clearly not
more mature just more
guarded so it was a mask yeah
100 so then you still had to yeah that
makes that makes sense
just protection you know it's the fight
or flight thing it was like i'm going to
fight and i'm going to just
do what i can to survive this this
situation and not that it was bad
yeah um but it's definitely not normal
for a 10 year old
yeah yeah there's so much i've been
unpacking
2020 has been for everybody it's been
big but
yeah there's been a lot of things that
have happened and really uncovering what
makes us who we are today and like what
gives us what
where do our triggers come from why do
we end up
projecting or putting a mask up you know
for certain situations
guarding um some people self-sabotage
some people clang some people fear
abandonment
and like it ends up you know it ends up
being a really therapeutic process but
you realize it all comes from
childhood oh 100 i mean everything and
i've done so much work
energetically i've done so much work
emotionally i've seen it it's
amazing i love that you show people
those other modalities
yeah i think i'm i'm a feeler like my
whole motto is like i feel i feel and
that's how i articulate
um what i'm going through is my feeling
and my expression first and then i find
my words
and so the movement the dance the
the crying the energy work all that
stuff to me is
is so natural and it just it's like oh
this is my language
but i just started talk therapy like for
the first time ever
and that has been so interesting for me
because
oh i know it's like all my
compartmentalization that i'm so good at
and have been doing for
25 years just when all the walls came
down it was just like a flood
of everything you say the words
oh yeah when you say it it becomes real
and it's a reality
and then you're like oh my gosh there's
been a through line of of
my behavior my like not even behavior
that's even a
strong word to use but of why your
pattern
yeah of why you are the way you are and
why you do the things that you do
not just the situation that happened and
then release it
you know like i've been very good to
like acknowledge and then like
release and move forward yeah instead of
being like oh no i kind of actually need
to carry this with me a little bit
just for the time being to understand
my the reason why i feel abandonment and
betrayal and why it's so heavy and why
it's like the minute i feel it i go
and like you can't get in here at all if
i feel that
tiniest little bit and this whole year
so you
have a fear of abandonment yet you put
the wall up too abandonment and betrayal
the thing that i don't want
it's like i completely um protect myself
from even
getting yeah you kind of self-sabotage
in a way because when you put the wall
up you
kind of might get abandoned exactly oh
man it's so hard to unpack all this crap
but i feel like and i feel like this
year more so than ever
like you know or fellow hippies i don't
know how you got under your hip
but and where it originated and what
your first memories of it were but
timelines feel so accelerated this year
yeah like a decision
or something that's going on with
yourself or with
emotions or society like everything's
going so fast
yeah so fast i think it's because
there's actually space
like yeah usually we're just on like the
hamster wheel and we're just
going going going and so we just
procrastinate
i think the the things that are actually
clawing at us we just kind of let it
drag on
whereas like there's been so much space
that you're like sitting with it
so much more clearly and you're like
okay this is not
this is not what i want anymore and like
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna sit in the [ __ ] like this
is
you know life is precious life is short
and it's long
like well when it's not good it's long
right and when it's good it flies by
yeah
what is the what's the what's the thing
that you're like i'm never doing this
anymore like i learned my lesson
i got this one i learned my lesson until
the next time
that's fine i heard this expression new
level new devil
yeah so sometimes you go a little deeper
and it kind of shows itself in a new way
right like
the journey's never over it's just how
do you get to a place where
for me it's like i'm feeling like my
heart's broken open
so that i actually feel more pain yeah
but i actually feel
way more joy too yeah i talk about it as
like the pendulum swing it's like we've
been so right here and like
this is just like the range and it's
like oh i feel all of it now and
i sometimes i'm like oh the red pill or
the blue
i'm like can i can i not can i go back i
just sometimes don't want to feel like
we do like weekdays with one in the
weekends with the other
you should develop it's been a range for
sure
i feel the grief this year there's been
a lot of grief i think just
the opposition of love is grief and so
like to be able to experience it and
feel it now
i've grown in my empathy which i've
always been able to have compassion for
people
and like i feel for them but to
actually have empathy i thought i had
and but until this year i don't really
think i had
reached that level do you remember when
was there something that happened that
you
it hit you it sat with you yeah so
going through my separation um my
my mom and my oldest sister they both
got divorced
and there were situations within family
that they didn't feel supported and
yet and i was one of those people that
they didn't feel supported by and i was
like but i was there the whole time like
what do you mean i i was there if you
needed me
and and i realized now being in my own
separation i was like
wow it's not about just somebody being
there like
physically like it's really about
like reaching out not just saying i'm
here if you need me
but like let me think about being in
that person's shoes
knowing my sister she's not gonna reach
out so like
let me go surprise her bring her some
food or like let me go like
i don't know do something that speaks
her language
and i never did that for my sister and i
remember just like
calling her up and crying and being like
i am so
sorry i thought i was there for you
because i was
in my own way like saying like
i don't know possibly judging but also
just being like yeah i'm doing the best
that i can
i'm thinking about myself not thinking
about her at all and so
i just yeah i remember calling her up
but i'm like i'm so sorry
i apologize i will never not be there
for you ever again and so
there's a lot of i will never not do
that
um that i've learned this year because
of my own experience
what else do again abandon myself
and i think that that's a little bit of
the abandonment betrayal
of like the fear from others when it's
actually really from myself
because i'm so afraid to lose myself
within people
now and situations and work and
because i'm i'm so good at giving and
and i don't mean like i'm such a great
giver
i give but i just it's just my natural
default of
the more i give the more
like i'm rewarded by it i feel good i
feel really good i
i get that and then i'm like oh wow i
really haven't given
to myself at all so self-love compassion
it's like the oldest
thing that people are like you have to
love yourself first
but it's so true that is like
such a thing that is said all the time
and i've heard it too
and yes i love myself like there's no
way i haven't loved myself
in my life but i've found that it's like
love yourself enough for
love yourself enough for for me it's
been boundaries yeah but for some others
it's um
vulnerability yeah i'm kicking them off
now
yeah let's let's kick them off because
it's like
we we're we're we're uh we're deep in
this uh
in this super comfortable chair but i
feel like we're gonna get into it now
i know i'm like sweating on the inside i
know we're gonna keep my hair in front
but no it's coming back
yeah yeah you said judgments too and
that's something that i was watching a
video the other day
it was i think it was a teal swan video
do you ever watch her on
yeah i watch youtube videos all the time
and
um it was about judgment and how
it was like making a list of the things
that you judge and then recognizing
that you deny them in yourself
what are you judging by that's good oh
i mean it's always a reflection right so
um i don't know i think i have the i
have a work hard mentality
so so i
i expect a lot from people and if
they're
you know i'm pretty bad though like i
have
22 employees and so like i'll call and
be like
hey so i just sent you this property so
we could look for our studio
um um send it over you know like 15
minutes i'm late later i'm like
so did the realtor get back and they're
like oh i haven't sent it yet i'm like
well why not
so you judge lazy efficiency
yeah but then i but then here's my
pattern it's it's like
i judge i'm like come on efficiency get
to get to work you know because that's
what i would do
and then i feel guilty for then
expecting too much
so then it's like i go into punishment
mode for myself double whammy yourself
oh i shovel women right i'm literally
it's the worst
i literally go like push punish
push punish so that's that's what i'm
working on right now
what if you didn't punish yourself
that's what i'm working on
right now i mean like one of the other
like start
somewhere right totally yeah i would i
would actually be
i think better by the non-punishing
versus the expecting because in
relationship it's different you want to
not expect certain things but
in work like there's there is an
expectation yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's a great thing so i i do
talk therapy too
um i have to actually didn't do therapy
until i did therapy back in the day i
used to be married like nobody
nobody remembers that or knows that but
or thinks about that but i was
and i did a lot of talk therapy back in
those days and then didn't do it for a
long time and then got back into it and
it was that
you know uh love can be unconditional
but relationships have to have
conditions conditions
yeah for boundaries for taking care of
yourself will you say that again
um that love can be unconditional but
relationships
cannot that's relationships are
conditional yeah that's really good to
take care of yourself and to tell the
other person how to take care of you
yeah
totally you say what you need yeah so
that can that can show up obviously in
romantic it shows up the most
right um but it shows up in the other
ones too yeah
clear clear boundaries and expectation
levels for things so that's not yours
boundaries i never had any yeah ever
because i'm like i'm a giver like you
it comes from sort of the the cancer
motherly nature like take care of like
i've just got a
boat tunnel libra in me so like i'm just
like i
like making other people happy makes me
happy totally so it's tricky because
it's like such a fine line in there
and i think a lot of people probably you
know feel this whether or not you know
crap about astrology or not
taking care of someone feels good yeah
but you got to know where the edge is
and where you start to lose yourself
yeah and
you know i don't know maybe it's like do
something for them
three times in a row and then something
for you i don't know it might have to be
simple but
for me it was like being by myself for
the first time in
100 years and then writing down
boundaries
yeah writing them down i was like oh my
god boundaries not literally a line in
the sand it's not like
don't cheat on me it's like oh energetic
exchanges
it's like it's like so much more nuanced
yeah oh it totally is and i find that it
like
they it literally the same lesson shows
up whether it's in friendship or
relationship or work
all at the same time so again like a
work situation
when covet happened i like opened up my
home and we created a studio in the
basement
and it was beautiful and it was oh thank
you and it was awesome and i was like
yeah come on over
and i was like oh my gosh at one point i
had so many people at my house
constantly that
like i remember i wanted to like cry one
day in my house and i felt like i had to
be quiet
in my own house to like express myself
and i was like there's so many people
and then i realized oh my gosh
i'm now liable if anything were to ever
happen and i
my brain doesn't go there because i
immediately go oh yeah of course let's
open up my house i have the space let's
do this
or it's your birthday do you want my
house sure have a party
like that's my gut like that's it just
happens
and then i say it and then i'm like can
i take that back
whoops so the boundary thing for me i
have to think
i really have to think before i speak
yeah have you
like found one that you're like this is
the one really really really really
important one that i'm not gonna
overlook anymore
um i i think it's my health really
yeah like someone who's like so
beautiful so fit
like i would never guess that no it's my
health but
then like physical or like physical
health and emotional
um but it's tied to the emotional like
my adrenals are completely shot
like i got my vitals taken almost a year
ago and it was like i had a marker not
quite yet but like a marker for an
autoimmune because
probably ebstein bar because just like
exhaustion and yeah and i and i'm like
oh wow it's because
i don't know what to do if i'm not
working like there's something so
rewarding and it's not about the
achievement at the end it's just the
i have this too like i love to work like
and i love to grow and so and i love to
create so there's
like i feel so alive when i'm working
but then i push it so
far that that i crash and then i ha
and then i either get really sick for
like a week and then i get back into it
or not so
um so i think for me it's more just
i i need to take care of my health
because i i can
feel if i don't
like my body will shut down so getting
more sensitive to it now yeah you start
to kind of you can kind of like sense it
feel it
yeah i can notice it oh yeah is there a
certain thing that you've implemented
now
with your team maybe it's like a plan
for schedule wise or
yeah it's and yeah and that's what i do
too is like i love a schedule so
if i don't have one i'm all over the
place like
free break get along i love to play too
yeah i'm a future caster not a past i
don't look to the past
i look to the future i think people are
one or the other
like you either ruminate on the past and
memories and have
sadness and guilt or you look to the
future and when things don't happen
you feel uh you know you're you're
attached
that's the attachment yeah right like ah
it didn't happen and you keep grasping
for it
and you don't know when to let that go
and let something else come in
yeah yeah i'm right in that place right
now too
i kind of feel like i'm in this void
place right now where
like i'm quite i got one go get the one
i know i'm like i don't really
i'm not stuck i actually feel really
free and like
flowy but i don't know where i'm going
like i have no clue have you i have
no idea that's actually i'm gonna say
that's kind of amazing and fun
have you fallen i just had this i was
doing this meditation circle last night
with kimberly snyder i don't know
um and we were talking about sort of
getting into this
getting into the universal flow like
like setting back and letting things
come to you
have you have you experienced those
times where you can like
vaguely make plans and vaguely start to
sort of have intentions but not be so
locked and not be so
attached to the way that they need to go
that you go how did that
just unfold better than i can you could
you didn't even have to ask somebody to
quit
to cancel their plans they got canceled
and you're like well that's perfect
and have you have you gotten there it
does this
um i will say and this is i think my big
lesson in life is the less i do the more
[ __ ] happens
because the minute i relax
and i take a breath and i actually take
a break
i went to maui in june because my
friends had a house there and i just was
like i just need to get away i was gonna
go for four days i stayed for a month
and the whole month that i was there i i
still worked a little bit but i
i surfed every morning got it like
pummeled every day it was the worst but
um surfed every day i made i made work
fit into my life
versus my life fit into my work and all
of a sudden
like everything just opened up work wise
and it completely like i did nothing
and i'm like wait this is gonna be bad
like you want success do nothing
but but it's true like i know for me i'm
such an
energetic being and like if i ask for
something
it happens i mean that's everyone but
like i know that that's my gift like i'm
such a visceral
energetic human that if i'm clouded with
all the stuff
and like the the tasks and like the
doing
which i've been doing a lot of recently
having you know a business
that's i'm a creative um so like doing
that it's weird
but just honestly like doing nothing and
feeling my best
everything just started pouring in and
so such a great lesson yeah and so i'm
like
i know it it's just it's i have to
constantly remind myself because i love
to work
so and you get attached and so then you
think if i work a little
like i'll just do a little bit more it's
uh i've said it many times but when i
retired i
felt like it was the first time that i
started to get
a feel for the difference between
quitting and letting go
right like sometimes you just kind of
got to let go of things a little bit
yeah
and see what was that process like for
you i mean it was
like i had a my major sponsor just
decided to stop
paying the bills at the beginning of a
season before the season even started
and so then it was like oh god is the
team gonna tell me i can't drive now and
but i still raced and um but
finding another sponsor was necessary
so it's just a process that i was like
at first i was scared to be done
and i was like oh that felt good to me
to actually be scared to be done because
i yeah i've actually the truth is and
people find this kind of
surprising but i i never really loved
racing
i loved aspects of it um
that really kept me very into it but
like it loving it itself
and the racing like i don't go do it i
don't need to go drive a car
i don't so um i i
you know i just kind of really felt into
that a little bit more and was like let
i maybe it's time maybe like it felt
like it was hard felt like so much
effort
and and i really if i'm being honest
like there was such an energetic shift
in me going on with all of my other
interests with yeah you know everything
from
uh you know the nature of reality to
crystals to you know
raising my frequency that i stopped
resonating with it your identity was
shifting like that was it for so long
it just didn't resonate anymore i didn't
feel good have you ever been in those
environments where you just kind of like
you're there and everything seems fine
and all of a sudden you just kind of go
like
i don't know like it's just i'm not
feeling it like the people the vibe
like i don't know you just grow out of
it yeah
i've been in it probably about 10 times
in my life
wow i feel like i've had like 30
different lives like growing up in utah
growing up in england
having uh being on dancing with the
stars having a music career
having an acting career like i did so
many different things that they were all
identity shifts for me
every single time even like dancing with
the stars seems like a long time ago
when you start i mean
i was 18. you were dear elio's partner
[Music]
but no but so those i feel that but i
think that the
the identity of the attachment sometimes
like
i had to kind of discover what i even
liked anymore because
i was just so used to dancing and i was
so used to singing and acting and like
that was what i made up my mind i was
gonna do forever
that like i didn't
know if i was really enjoying it i just
was
doing it because it was comfortable
and so like i kind of realized i was
like am i just
putting myself in an emotional home
that's actually comfortable but actually
not
really fulfilling my
my soul purpose but my
whether it's my ego purpose or whatever
but like but i still love
like i love it because it's familiar
totally but i'm like but is it actually
what do you do for fun
what do you do for fun well i don't talk
about it on the show or
no i mean that's actually a whole other
story today
no try to find myself what i like you
know like i didn't know
what i liked because i was just so i was
so future of what i
thought should be that i would just go
for it and be that
create who i am versus be who i am
it's like you didn't take enough time
maybe to really like
i don't know you're just such an easy
manifesto that you
it all started un rolling out really
quick it sounds like
everything you think of it rolls out
really quick and then you're in it you
don't really have a chance to sort of
assess early enough or even along the
way because it
keeps going everything you do turns to
gold that like you're like
whoa and this is what i am now kind of
yeah like i remember when i was starting
my music
i just i wanted to be a singer so i was
like i'm going to be a singer
and then i was doing country music and i
was like
i love country music but like i want to
dance and sing like i i don't want to
i don't want to play and sing and so
like it was and it was so different yeah
that i was like this isn't actually
really
what i want to do but this was but i
said i wanted that and so it happened
all right so yeah so for me i have to be
i have to be
very careful with my words because
like yeah exactly like
that's amazing and it's such a rare
thing
it's uh it's a blessing and a curse in a
way so let's play a little game so
um i've never done this before but i'm
just thinking to myself like maybe this
is like the ultimate sort of like or
this is a
a way of testing or checking yeah um
so what if uh what if somebody said you
could never sing again
oh there's going to be a lot of these
questions so yeah yeah
go with you you know i think
it would be really hard all right what
if i told you that you
could never journal again
i would be okay with that like versus
singing i can do that
okay yeah uh what if i told you
that uh
you could never dance again
well first of all when you said sing or
dance i was like well that could never
happen because
like i just have to i wouldn't do it for
other people i would do it for myself
so yeah so i could actually
not sing or dance for the world
or for people but i would have to do it
yeah no this is alone like if you were
like alone
this is your like weekend like if i told
you like the rest of your life like
it doesn't matter if you're on tv for it
or not like you can never sing again
oh that was just heartbreaking okay you
can never dance again heartbreaking okay
you can never journal again
i'd be okay with that okay you could
never uh
you energetically you're you're
you're staying here you can't grow
there's no more lessons to be learned
i would die that's a big one then yeah
that's a really big one
yeah um you can never drink again
totally fine oh yeah i feel like i was
like totally fine
like i like what i feel like in the
morning when i don't drink
but i do like throw a funny one in what
else um you could
never um
you couldn't have more than one job
oh that's a tough one you gotta pick one
like could you live that way
that would i don't know if i could that
would be hard for me because i
i love to create i found recently that
the reason why i love
acting or being on tour or a tv show is
because they're their projects their
bite size it's like you focus for three
to six months
you do a project it's like complete and
then you can move on to another one
it's still in the same vein but it's a
new
it's something new okay then a twist on
that is that you could never create you
have to pick one job that you have right
now
okay or actually how about you just
don't get to pick new you don't get to
dream up new jobs everything that you've
started
okay is the rest of your life now no
more new jobs no more new crates no more
new creative ventures
could you stick with what you've got
right now would you be okay i think
that's probably what i should do
actually okay um because i would love to
be able to focus
in on that and like expand on what's
already
my creative gift versus adding stuff
that
doesn't really matter i think that
i mean i i mean that seemed really
obvious to me that the growth is the
most important
element of anything and everything and
that that your
soul yearns to continue to evolve and
grow
yeah uh and that it just seems like you
need to dive into what you've got right
now
and expand it like yeah you know help
wake people up with them yeah well
actually that's
been over the last three years when i
started kinergy when
when i really honed in my production
company i realized
everything was so siloed before and so
compartmentalized that
they were all different brands and
things
and it didn't really feel complete and
now i'm like oh
everything has a through line now
transformation identity
and self-discovery wow and it can be in
film it can be in television it can be
in dance it can be in kinergy it can be
yeah in my music everything has that
yeah
that through line so it feels like one
now it all went from this to like
when kynergy came together would you say
yes that kind of weird energy was like
the manifestation of like what i can
give to others but really what i was
going through
like what i needed for me to be able to
find that through line of like who i
am in everything that i do were you
practicing
sort of a variation of kinergy the way
that you would teach it now
for yourself um like how did how was it
born much more much more woo-woo than
what i
teach oh yeah do the wubu version yeah
the version you kind of want to do alone
don't you
i'm cool doing it with people because i
love people but i think
the whole point of kinergy was to create
something that was accessible
for people who need that bridge
um that it's too woo-woo you know and
that are a little bit more
on the science side of things or a
little bit more structured
i call it 3d 40 or 5d and so i'm like
we're really like crushing like trying
to get people for
in the 3d world to get them kind of to
the 5d
but like you can't just give them five
energies kinergy's like four
but we're like trying to bring those
people in while not alienating anybody
else so
beautiful yeah and then it's like once
you get it and you're like
what what now i want to know more than
offering more workshops and to dive
deeper
is that something that's available yet
january oh yeah
yeah so we will get there hang on i
learned all about that yeah okay
but but kinergy to me like it's yeah you
said it
it just like it packed all of the
elements into one
but it was a personal practice yes
generally
first and so like
do you remember like when you first did
something that was sort of the essence
of kinergy
for yourself i mean
let's see how i think i've
always been doing it and i think that
that's why this feels more like my
my soul's purpose versus my expression
you know
and like my creativity not that they're
different but one is like more
self-fulfilling and one is for
the the world or others or whatever
it is outside of myself and the
contribution and so
when i look back in my through line like
i've always danced
more freely than than
other kids in my classes or when i would
train or
when i would compete i was never the
best dancer like the most technical
i didn't have like that's not why i won
i won because i was magnetic
and free and expressed
and i made people feel something
versus just what they were looking at
was right because you were feeling it
because i felt it it's like that it's
like the end of black swan yeah and she
gets really into it like
she becomes it like yes she's feeling it
and that resonates yes
so so i think for me it was just like
when you can kind of just surrender
your mind to your body and just
completely open up to like
there is no right or wrong there is no
good or bad
it's just it's you then
yeah that's that's just what k energy's
about and then you add in
technicalities to just expand it like
boundaries like you kind of do need
boundaries in a framework
to maximize maximize the explosion
because otherwise it's just it'll just
go everywhere to have a container to
kind of hold it in
creates even more of a vortex i feel
like i could say all this with you yeah
it like holds it and builds all that
energy whereas
if you don't have structure like the the
breath work for kinergy
or the visualization through the
elements that helps you
surrender your mind so you're
visualizing your breathing
and then you have a certain form of
structure
but it's not about that it's just to
have the framework so that you can
like blow up basically
and like raise your own vibration and
energy within yourself
the container being the structure
or essentially just saying for this hour
or for this half hour
yeah for this all of that for this 40
minutes yeah
there's movement there's breath and then
there's imagination those are the three
pillars
that give you that structure in that
container but
you can express yourself in any regard
so whether it's your life force energy
your emotional field
um your expression yeah
whatever you want to do in that moment
where do you think that
we as humans are going to have the most
amount of growth
i'm asking a kind of broad question but
i i have some of my own perspectives on
it but
maybe i'll back up and say i'm learning
the value
through doing like doing kinergy and
recognizing just how like
even something simple for me like it was
fun to do something that was
out of i'm so structured and i'm like do
25 reps of this and then 15 of that and
then five of that and then five rounds
of it and it's like
and you're on a clock and it was like
just move and you're like well that's
what do i do okay i'm so glad i'm alone
right now
but also like the non-structure or just
sort of
but then also through over time too
since i've done that i've done a lot
more um
whether it's even body work with audible
sounds so
kind of like feel somatic a little bit
um
but yeah just adding voice adding
intention
yeah um movement uh there's a lot
there and so you know for me i've had a
lot of growth
that comes from feeling like when i do
those things i take an emotion that's
trapped somewhere in the body
yes and i give it a door yeah and then
it flows out and then all of a sudden
i'm crying at the end that's exactly
what it is
he was so mean you know whatever it
means or i didn't realize that i just
need to choose myself
i know it's so true though but that's
what it is and i don't think people give
themselves permission enough
to to to let go or to stop holding it
together and by the way i'm the biggest
culprit of that i'm so responsible i
hold everything together i
make sure i show up on time except for
today you know like
certain things you're right
but the things that i i'm so used to
holding together and so
we all do that though like if you know
if we're not used to
being like actually making a sound that
is the
most uncomfortable awkward thing to do
but
nobody cares yeah and and like i look at
like
culturally and like historically
when we look at like tribes and
communities i mean
there's there's there's no shame there's
sounds and music and dancing and being
naked and i'm not
you know telling people to be naked
please no don't quote me there
but but there's a freedom but there's a
freedom
i know but there is like kids the same
thing like they're not worried if
they're doing something right or wrong
they're just
being and they're expressing themselves
and then they learn
and they're figuring out what life is
but we've completely started adulting to
where we're like shutting down
maybe what our instinct wants to do and
then we're like completely limiting
ourselves to
what's possible so that's to me
as silly as it is but it your question
of like where do you think the biggest
growth for humans is is
learning about themselves like what is
it that i want how do i
how do i feel free within myself
so that i can explore
and find that out and then and then like
you find your tribe and your people and
like
all of a sudden they just you don't have
to go looking
all the sudden like your circle just
gets bigger and people start coming into
your circle
and it's like oh i have my people i've
always had my people
i just didn't i didn't meet them yet you
know like
so i don't know i just i feel like
i went to davos this last year and it
was like for the
world economic forum and everybody's
talking about sustainability and the
the world and how to save the planet and
economics and all this stuff
and i'm like so none of this is gonna
work
unless you actually come from the inside
out like if we're just trying to go from
the outside in trying to fix
problems like none of this is going to
work like you have to
actually find like a belief in yourself
that you actually care and that's
something that you
want to do and you can't fix everything
so find something that you're excited
about that you're passionate about
and and come from that place versus
this this place if like you said if we
can just look
at ourselves and go if i just changed me
but if everyone did that now and said if
i just change me
then and i fix me i heal me yeah
i fill in those gaps of judgments that
are
you know exposing something i deny
myself they're filling in the gaps of
you know traumas that i you know have
kept
hold of that i then project because
someone pokes at my wound
yeah like if i can fix and fill in all
this all this
brokenness inside of me and then
you actually you are changing the world
more than if you just went way more
screamed at the top of a mountain where
everyone's down at the bottom going
make sure you recycle like i mean
you know it might not be popular for
saying it but i think there are just so
many things that exist
that are just distraction they're just i
don't know i don't know what's going on
under the surface i don't know what's
going on really out there i don't know
who's really in control
i don't know what shit's going on but i
know that there's so much going on that
just feels like distraction
whether it's politics or some shows or
like there's stuff that just feels to me
like gosh i'm like really
like is that what we're spending our
time and money and effort and
energy on when you could be waking up
and
doing morning pages like you encourage
people to do and journaling and writing
and
you know expressing yourself and getting
in touch with yourself emotionally and
encouraging people to look within
like that kinergy is to go like i want
to give you
this container to open your heart
completely
that's that's honestly really what it is
like people are like oh it's a dance
workout i'm like no
no it's it's like a transformation slash
like self-discovery slash like
de-layering of all the conditioning and
the [ __ ] that we've
built up and it's not our fault like
it's society it's parents it's religion
it's culture it's
it's social media it's everything and
it's like how do i
actually just get to that place where i
trust myself
and then when that happens like you
shift
and then your environment shifts your
the people around you start shifting
and then you know it's it's like coven
it's like
one in three people yeah but with
like healing and then once that happens
then people start having empathy and
like a real
care for simplicity and you know and
like
they can actually look at the world
around them and be like oh my gosh i
actually care about that tree
whereas i'm so bogged with all of my own
suffering i call it suffering instead of
suffering
that's great words but instead of all my
own suffering i can actually
notice and see the plants
like nobody can even see the planet
right now because
we're in our own [ __ ] and like
and our relationships are maybe surfaced
because everybody's afraid
of being rejected and you know and it's
like
ugh it like it breaks my heart
especially again because i feel like you
go through cycles like
last year i was like clear as a freaking
whatever
something that is that's clear clear
reports just clear courts i was so clear
and then and then i lost my girls and
then that suffering hidden and that
grief
and then i went through separation and
then like i isolate when
i'm feeling bad so then i felt a loss
from family and friends and
and so that clarity that i had
and this is my punisher i would punish
myself for not being there again you
know but i'm like no this is part of it
it's another cycle it's another layer of
like i've never felt this kind of grief
before
and now i can see someone and actually
have a conversation with them and listen
and talk versus versus everything's all
great and
amazing but not sit in the [ __ ] you know
you're fun to watch you've got tons of
energy
and i'm like there's no way you're that
happy all the time
but what's funny is i thought i was yeah
i don't i
totally believe it was real for me in
that moment because that's all i knew
and that's what i'm saying is like i
lived like this
and was i positive like yeah
and that got me so far but that's why
i'm worried about my health because i'm
so tired i'm literally so tired
and i and i'm learning i'm like it's my
body is so tired my mind is so tired
because i was
literally trying to fit in this like
tiny little like perfect
box of i have to always stay positive i
have to make sure everybody else is good
you know and and then it started opening
i was like nobody's gonna like me
my personality is gone like i am boring
but i'm like oh i'm just calm and i
actually have
it's better it's more range it's more
relatable
i resonate with you and i felt like i
don't resonate with that
like i i mean totally i followed you for
a reason a long time ago
yeah at that vulnerability it's so i
mean it's such a common word now but
it's true it's like
it's the key yeah i agree how are you
really feeling like when i asked him
like how are you and
i'm fine like no no no i asked how you
are yeah
and it's autopilot for for most humans
you know like we're fine
my sister said it to me today i was like
you are so lying
and she's like i just can't talk right
now i was like well why don't you just
say that then
like stop saying you're fine because
you're not
that's a great lesson because you said i
really was happy then and so it's okay
if you feel like you're there and it's
okay
then break down because new level new
devil like you wanted to go deeper you
wanted
your soul was calling your heart to
expand and break open
and it finally like you know the the
like they say you know the whisper
becomes the scream becomes a
quake like it's just you are so focused
you're such a hard worker uh you're such
a manifestor
and you have such an incredible team
around you obviously you just keep
going like it took an earthquake it did
and it was a it was a heartbreaking one
and
i had them for 11 and 8 years i would
have nightmares
about how they died and they died that
same way
when you think about like i don't know
you know you get these intuitions you
get these thoughts
and then let's say it happens and i've
had that where i'm thinking like this
this is like worst case scenario yeah
and then it happens i really wonder am i
that intuitive
or did i create it how did i create it
yeah totally what do you think
um i mean it's two things oh my gosh i'm
about to make a race card
reference good stuff when the race car
driver is looking at the wall they're
gonna hit the wall
that's all right so um so yeah i
i'm supposed to make you feel good
you're making me feel good so
what's uh i mean like we've talked a lot
about we've talked about
i feel like in general uh this sort of
general idea but what do you what have
you identified as your purpose
my purpose is to continue dis
continuing like discovering who i am
growing
so that i can be an inspiration
or and not to be an inspiration but i
can inspire
or emulate or radiate
what's possible for others inside of
themselves
because i think that that's i i do feel
like i'm an entertainer for a reason
like there's i have something about me
that people like to watch
so i i have a responsibility to make
sure that what i'm doing
is is intentioned and it's
it's it's not that it's not
gonna be pure all the time but then it's
coming from a pure place and that like
still ups and downs and things are gonna
happen but that i'm doing you know the
best that i can
in my pursuit of happiness and my
pursuit of
freedom and my pursuit of um
i don't know just expression and and i
and i really do believe that
where mirrors and everyone sees
themselves
in each other and you see that you see
the great you see the shadow side you
see all the different things and so
i want to be as true and authentic and
pure as i can be so that
that person can see themselves as well
and i can then see myself in you and
like
we we can just i don't know we can just
help each other grow
i just want to love everybody basically
i just want to love on everyone
and just um yeah and just
understanding that power of loving
yourself so that you can yeah
but there isn't judgment anymore exactly
fill in those gaps
yeah and i think like
i'm i'm finding this new sense of
simplicity like trust me like i want a
lot of money because i want to share it
i want to do things i want to play
i want to do all those things but i was
looking out my bedroom window
the other day and like when i built the
house i see the hollywood sign it was
such like a moment for me and i remember
looking at it
kind of at the beginning of covet and i
was looking at it and i was like
none of this is real i was like
what is this and like that hollywood
sign
like what and i was
and then i like got really deep with it
and i was like looking behind it and i
was like
that's just held up by stilts and it's
on a dirt
mountain and i was like
none of this is real what am i doing
here and i was like
i don't know if i belong here and then i
went into this whole
like kind of out of body experience
where i was like what is
what is what is my purpose of my life
like
and then i realized oh i can still do
everything that i'm doing
but i don't have to put so much
importance on it like
the even kinergy like i put so much
importance on it because i was like
this is helping people this is healing
people and then i was like
whoa you're losing you're losing the
purity of like
if it does it does great if it doesn't
it doesn't
what's that beautiful analogy of like
you know when you when you want
something so badly
knowing that you're holding if you want
it so badly and you're grasping and
thinking
you're also holding an energetic chord
to it that is the fear it won't happen
and since that totally universe can't
really tell the difference between
the fear and like it's not going to
happen to i want it to it's not going to
happen i want it it's not going to
happen
and then all it does just sit there and
goes like just no no no no
and it doesn't actually accelerate it's
high what's the right one or the wrong
one
right just is both there yeah right it's
the same kind of energy in fact i
i was really pushed and drawn by
negative charge
energy and that's pretty much how i got
successful
um by pushing the interview all over
again
but being like this watch me and and i
got
really successful because of that
negative spiral
you know what though it all led you to
here
completely all part of your path all
part of the all part of like the lessons
learned
and thank goodness i be grateful found
it now
at 30 you know i'm 32 but at 30 yeah
instead of at 60 you know yeah take the
lessons
when and wherever they come and look
back in gratitude
and you know it's like when someone says
ah you've changed like what would you
say to him thank you
yeah yeah thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button